it's a victory for those and don't want
to be forced what to write whether an
ink or I see people who only want cake
not words to be put in their mouth when
they don't agree with the customer's
message
Gareth Lee is a gay rights campaigner in
Northern Ireland the only part of the UK
where equal marriage is still illegal a
Christian owned bakery rejected his
order he had to take his business
elsewhere but five Supreme Court judges
decided this was not discrimination
their objection was to the message on
the cake and not to the personal
characteristics of mr. Lee or of anyone
else with whom he was associated two
courts had previously ruled against
Asher's bakery the thirty-six pound cake
has now run up legal bills of half a
million pounds we always knew we hadn't
done anything wrong and turning down
this order after more than four years
the Supreme Court has now recognized
that and we're very grateful grateful to
the judges and especially grateful to
God the Supreme Court moved to Belfast
for a two-day hearing on the case
earlier in the year the judges insist
the ruling should not diminish from
genuine discrimination but mr. Lee
disagrees that made me feel like a
second-class citizen and the judgement
today tells me that that's okay I can
Belfast mr. Lee's fellow campaigners say
there are implications way beyond the
gay rights issue I think there is a
fundamental question here as to whether
or not a printer printing a particular
message is them endorsing that message
the reality is that if you offer a
service you must offer that service to
everyone on an equal basis
at this printing business they take the
view that the customer is always right
in what they want written it doesn't
make you think if somebody came to me
and said I want a t-shirt that says I
oppose gay marriage you wouldn't turn
that down even though you get a lot of
business from the gay community no I
wouldn't because it's business its
business correct
you got afford to turn down business
well yes correct that's that's that's
true too it's a sweet victory for the
Baker's but leaves a sour taste in the
mouths of those who had their cake and
ate it
in woods Sky News Belfast